انطلاق الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد وطول امد
الحرب في اوكرانيا دفع القياده روسيه
لاعتماد سياسه توفير الاسلحه والذخائر
واستبدال ما تستطيع منها باسلحه فعاله
ورخيصه بذات الوقت فوزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه قالت ان موسكو
وبمساعده ايرانيه بدات بانتاج طائرات
مسيره محليه الصنع لتقليل استخدام صواريخ
كروز هذا فيما يتعلق بجديد الاخبار تلك
الطائرات المسيره ستكون رخيصه الثمن وايضا
ستؤدي الدور المطلوب منها بدلا من استخدام
صواريخ كروز ذات الكلفه العاليه وحتى ان
كان اثر المسيرات التدميري اقل واشنطن
كانت نشرت صوره ملتقطه بالاقمار الصناعيه
لموقع تم اختياره بحسب معلوماتها لانشاء
مصنع المسيرات هذا في منطقه بيلا بوجا كما
نتابع عند هذه النقطه هذه المنطقه
الاقتصاديه الخاصه وهي على مسافه نحو 900
كيلومتر شرق موسكو هذا المصنع الذي نتحدث
عنه وفق الاتهامات الغربيه تشيده موسكو
بمساعده طهران التي ترسل مواد لبنائه اما
المده المتوقعه لبدء الانتاج وبحسب الدفاع
البريطانيه فهو مطلع العام المقبل اي 20
وسرعه مخيفه بالتصنيع والشحن كشفها حطام
مسيره ايرانيه اسقطت في اوكرانيا في ابره
للماضي حيث اظهر تحليل للحطام وجود اجزاء
صينيه الصنع في طائره شاهد 136 بينها محول
جهد ومصنوع في يناير الماضي وفق وولد
الاكتشاف يظهر مدى سرعه تصنيع ايران
للمسيرات وشحنها الى روسيا فالجزء الصيني
صنع في منتصف شهر يناير ثم شحن الى ايران
ليتم تركيبه في الطائره قبل ارسالها الى
موسكو تعد هذه المره الاولى التي يعثر
فيها على جزء مصنوعه عام 2023 في المسيرات
الايرانيه علما بان روسيا اطلقت اكثر من
700 طائره من دون طيار لاستهداف محطات
توليد الكهرباء والمدن والاهداف العسكريه
وفقا للجيش الاوكراني وبحسب الاداره
الامريكيه طهران ارسلت الشهر الماضي مئات
الطائرات على مدن مد سفن تمر عبر بحر
قزوين بعد استنفاذ موسكو الامداداتها من
المصيرات دائره الانتاج الناشطه اذا هذه
وضع تحديات جديده امام واشنطن وحلفائها
تتمثل بمحاوله وقف تدفق كل المكونات من
جميع انحاء العالم باتجاه روسيا الى مصانع
المسيرات الايرانيه
غلطه الشاطر بالف لكن العبره في تعلم
الخطا هفوات فادحه كثيره وقعت بها موسكو
دفعتها لتطوير اسلحتها ومهاراتها جنرال
بريطاني متقاعد اكد انشاء الجيش الروسي
لخطوط دفاعيه شديده التحصين على طول خط
المواجهه الذي يبلغ طوله الفا كم اوضحت
موسكو تعلمت ابقاء المواقع المهمه مثل مقر
القياده مخازن ذخيره خارج نطاق المدفعيه
فوكاله السوشيت بريس اكدت ان موسكو تعلمت
من محاولتها الفاشله للسلعه على كيف وذلك
حين تقدمت القوافل العسكريه الروسيه
لاميال لتصبح فريسه سهله للمدفعيه
والمسيرات كما شحدت اسلحتها الالكترونيه
لتقليل التفوق الالكتروني في الطائرات
القتاليه من دون طيار وحولت القنابل
الثقيله من ترى سنتها الضخمه التي تعود
الحقبه السوفيتيه الى ذخائر انزلاقيه
موجهه بدقه هي قادره على ضرب الاهداف من
دون تعريض طائراتها الحربيه للخطر لكن ذلك
وكل رغم ذلك لا تزال روسيا تعاني نقاط ضعف
اساسيه تتمثل بالمعنويات المنخفضه لجنودها
نقص في ذخيره وسوء التنسيق بين الوحدات
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات